conan meet chloe hey chloe how are you
i'm
great how are you uh
i'm good now i uh yeah i'm i'm i'm
feeding off your enthusiasm
uh wow look at that you have you've
spelled out chill chums in letters on
your wall behind him
yes yes i i pulled a sona and dipped out
of work five hours early to decorate
oh chloe chloe i love you a good sona
slam
is always yes
oh i love you too chloe that's nice
that's can can a person be your spirit
animal is that possible
maybe yeah hopefully yeah i feel it's so
cool
yeah i feel like i don't know i hope the
exclamation
point may not be as chill but you know
yeah
chill chums exclamation points a little
uh like you're yelling it
you're angrily yelling it right um chloe
tell me a little bit about yourself
because i
i love meeting the people out there that
listen to us that have that kind of
patience
and level of self-esteem uh tell me
about what's your last name chloe
uh borah like like bora bora but half
the fun
you know oh wow okay wow wow you've got
a whole lot
worked out
i've tried that a couple times i'm not
gonna lie so that was like no
no it's good it's good when you get
something that works for you you stick
with it
yeah that's very good yeah uh so um
what do you do what do you do for a
living yes uh what's your trade so to
speak
so i'm uh i'm a copywriter so i
um i write instagram captions for what
for abercrombie
um abercrombie yeah oh you right oh you
write that
that's really good ad copy yeah i swear
to god i i'm not i'm not kidding i was
not being
uh like snarky or facetious the
abercrombie and fitch that's really nice
stuff
and when i read the descriptions i'm
drawn in oh wow
as i mean late at night if you're on the
abercrombie and fitch site
and uh you get you get pulled i mean i
go on some sites
you were on it late at night yeah what
are you doing what are you doing
on the site and you're just reading the
copy yeah
i really like the copy i could tell it
was
written abercrombie and fitch i'm listen
listen there's some attractive people in
there
um you know uh i thought maybe it was
possible to contact them through the
site it's not
honestly honestly conan you could be a
you could be a model
for them i could see it oh really yeah
no one's
that's very nice of you chloe but uh
i've been on this planet a long time and
no one's ever said you could model
without them revealing that it's one of
those prank shows hey okay
it's all about personality these days
anyway so
oh well why did you say that chloe
well then in that case you can't be well
yeah chloe
chloe why didn't you stick with it
double down and go those cheekbones
those piercing eyes the pompadour
that you're you're you're rakish gays
why couldn't you just double down you
immediately abandoned
i could be a model and went yeah it's
all about personality